[Música]
existe un concepto erróneo generalizado
que si le gusta organizar
meticulosamente sus cosas tener las
manos limpias o planificar su fin de
semana hasta el último detalle es
posible que tenga Toc
de hecho el Toc trastorno obsesivo
compulsivo es una condición psiquiátrica
grave que con frecuencia es mal
interpretada por la sociedad y Los
profesionales de la Salud Mental por
igual así que vamos a empezar a
desmitificarlo mito 1 las conductas
repetitivas o los rituales son sinónimos
de Toc como su nombre lo indica el
trastorno obsesivo compulsivo tiene dos
aspectos pensamientos intrusivos
imágenes o impulsos conocidos Como
obsesiones y compulsiones de
comportamientos que ejercen las personas
para aliviar la ansiedad que provocan
las obsesiones los tipos de acciones que
la gente a menudo asocia con el Toc como
el lavado de manos excesivo o el
comprobar cosas en varias ocasiones
pueden ser ejemplos de tendencias
obsesivas o compulsivas que muchos de
nosotros exhibimos de vez en cuando pero
el desorden real es mucho más raro y
puede ser muy debilitante Los afectados
tienen poco o ningún control sobre sus
pensamientos obsesivos y sus
comportamientos compulsivos que tienden
a consumir mucho tiempo e interferir con
el trabajo la escuela o la vida social
al punto de causar una significativa
angustia
estos criterios de diagnósticos son los
que separan a las personas que sufren de
teoc de los que solo pueden ser un poco
más meticulosos u obsesionados con la
higiene de lo habitual
mito 2 el síntoma principal del Toc es
el lavado de manos excesivo Aunque el
lavado de manos es la imagen más común
de teoc en la cultura popular las
obsesiones y compulsiones pueden tomar
muchas formas diferentes las obsesiones
pueden manifestarse como temor a la
contaminación y la enfermedad
preocupación de hacer daño a otros o
preocupaciones con números patrones
moralidad o la identidad sexual y las
compulsiones pueden ir desde la limpieza
excesiva o doble control a la colocación
meticulosa de los objetos o caminar en
patrones predeterminados
mito 3 los individuos con teoc no
entienden que están actuando y
racionalmente muchos individuos con teoc
de hecho entienden bastante bien la
relación entre sus obsesiones y
compulsiones
ser incapaz de evitar estos pensamientos
y acciones es parte de la razón por la
que el teoc es tan angustiante los
enfermos de teoce dicen sentirse locos
por experimentar la ansiedad basada en
pensamientos irracionales y que tienen
dificultad para controlar sus respuestas
Entonces qué causa el Toc La respuesta
es que no se sabe muy bien sin embargo
tenemos algunos indicios importantes el
teoc se considera un trastorno
neurobiológico En otras palabras la
investigación sugiere que los cerebros
de los pacientes con teoc están
programados para comportarse de cierta
manera la investigación implicó tres
regiones del cerebro involucradas en el
comportamiento social y la planificación
cognitiva compleja el movimiento
voluntario y las respuestas emocionales
y motivacionales la otra pieza del
rompecabezas es que el Toc está asociado
con bajos niveles de serotonina un
neurotransmisor que comunica a las
estructuras cerebrales y ayuda a regular
los procesos vitales como el estado de
ánimo la agresión el control de impulsos
el sueño el apetito la temperatura
corporal y el dolor
pero son la serotonina y la actividad en
estas regiones del cerebro la causa del
teoc o síntomas de una causa subyacente
desconocida del trastorno no lo sabremos
hasta que tengamos una comprensión mucho
más profunda del cerebro la buena
noticia es que hay tratamientos eficaces
para el Toc que incluyen medicamentos
que aumentan la serotonina en el cerebro
y limitan su reabsorción por las células
cerebrales terapia conductual que
desensibiliza gradualmente las
ansiedades y en algunos casos terapia
electroconvulsiva o cirugía cuando el
teoceno responde a otras formas de
tratamiento saber que su cerebro le
miente y al mismo tiempo no poder
oponerse a sus órdenes puede ser
agonizante pero con conocimiento y
comprensión se puede buscar ayuda y la
investigación Futura en el cerebro
finalmente podría proporcionar las
respuestas que estamos buscando
las afecciones de Salud Mental afectan a
millones de personas en todo el mundo
pero a menudo se malinterpretan
manténgase informado con este video
sobre la principal causa de discapacidad
en el mundo
[Música]